I want to go back to YouTube for a
moment what are some of the biggest
mistakes you see people make on YouTube
whether they're a vlogger whether they
want to do you know talking head style
documentaries whatever what are some of
the biggest mistakes you see other
youtubers make mistakes I see other
youtubers make
I would say one of the mistakes that's
the other youtubers make is not being
themselves you know people try to copy
or be like someone else or aspire to be
like someone else that they admire when
the best thing you can do is just be
yourself because no one can do you like
you can do so if you try to be someone
else you're not gonna be better at them
at that because that's what they do
especially if they're already big big
for that thing some people try to
replicate what they see and like it's
like when people for many years other
websites are trying to be the new
YouTube you can't be a new YouTube is
already it's it's it's it's it's a done
deal you can't be another YouTube you
can't be a new Michael Jackson so just
be yourself
hmm so you see people maybe being too
forced in a character type yes I
definitely see people trying to be too
forced or trying too hard when it's just
like what you just just do what you want
to do
you